hey everybody time for another movie
retrospective this is a [ __ ] weird
yeah I can't believe I didn't know this
one this is another one that kind of
like it's like the one we did last week
Alice sweet Alice this is one that's
like it's a really good movie but it
tends to like kind of fly under the
radar
yeah it's by the same people that did
like from beyond and stuff and it was
right along the lines of that but also
kind of like Naked Lunch - yeah it's
Burgie so yeah it's a trip this is
Society from 1989 although I should say
that it was released in Europe in 1989
and they [ __ ] loved it over there
yeah they didn't release it in the US
until 1992 I guess that's why I didn't
know about it and then it didn't do it
like it really got like kind of crappy
reviews nobody want to go see it it is
like a very very weird movie yeah I was
in the army that's why then that's right
yeah yes so I wouldn't have known about
it but you know had to come out a few
were a few years earlier you know before
I joined the army my friends were told
know about it cuz it fit right in with
re-animator and from beyond it's that
same kind of tone it didn't have of
course you know what's his name and
what's the guy's name did afraid who
played Herbert West yeah Jeffery come
yeah I didn't have Jimmy Combs in it but
you could tell it was yes it's the very
same it's a very body horror yeah um
honestly like I said it seems like it
kind of slipped under the radar a lot of
the times I think I first heard about it
I didn't see it at the time but I first
heard about it like um it comes up on a
lot of like horror movie lists with like
you know crazy as an era grossest ending
yeah and [ __ ] like that and rightly so
yeah so I finally got to see it on
shutter to shutter added it yeah several
months ago and I finally got around to
watching it every one of these every one
of the movies that came from this movie
kind of had some kind of body horror
type gimmick or some kind of gimmick to
it some kind of hook you know
yeah and the hook in this one incest
it says among many other yeah yeah and
bunch of other stuff too incest [ __ ]
with your mind I have to tell you right
now though you're like okay so if you
haven't seen this movie go get shudder
and watch it because you can't talk
about this movie without spoiling it
yeah
just can't it's just like one of those
movies like this movie is bonkers yes
the end of it is [ __ ] bonkers
yeah and that's me of that Lovecraft
movie with one that had Jeffrey Combs
with all the damn weird [ __ ] that
happened but she went at the end when
they go down they had the damn [ __ ]
weird bats what a microt nomicon
Necronomicon ik Bryan well this is the
same director oh is it okay there we go
yeah I was gonna say this was directed
by Bryan Jasna which horror fans will
know he's collaborated with Stuart
Gordon co-wrote like some of the
reanimate her films and produced the
first reanimate er and also like wrote
and directed bride of re-animator you
know so him and Stuart Gordon were big
buddies now Society was actually his
first movie his directorial debut and he
was like a writer and producer on a
bunch of other stuff he went on to like
I said he went on to direct very
famously bride of re-animator Return of
the Living Dead 3 also another rad movie
we need to do that one of these days
Necronomicon he also did be Andriy
animator yeah which we reviewed we were
feed Necronomicon tea I think
yeah yeah again but this was his first
movie yeah all these movies kind of fit
right in not so much castle freak no but
that was Stuart Gordon now but like I
said they're they're kind related
aesthetics are very simple we could tell
the castle freak is not part of this but
to me this is part of all the
reanimating from beyond and all them
yeah it has that tone this I would call
it I guess it's like it's like a horror
comedy but it's more of a satire um it's
kind of more along the lines somatically
it's very similar to like they live or
parents or invasion of the body
snatchers you know two Stepford Wives
it's just everything um a little bit of
dead and buried it has like a little bit
of that kind of vibe to or like a person
coming in town like everyone is you know
everyone is like in on it you know what
I mean
so it's like this really good like
paranoid kind of thing and like really
like other than like the batshit ending
yeah pretty much the first like our-our
10 minutes of it is kind of like a
mystery like a paranoid kind of mystery
yeah
rich people yes so you get like the main
character who's name is Bill Whitney I
think his name is yeah he's played by
Billy warlock who actually later went on
to be on like Baywatch and before this
he'd been on day
of our lives which I thought was very
funny are we getting into spoilers yeah
I said that before so there's no way to
talk about yes might as well check out
you know cuz now sometimes like I said
it's on shudder go watch it yeah back
because we you can't talk about it
without spoiling and even if you show
pictures of it like even the [ __ ]
cover kind of spoiled it yeah like some
of the DVD covers and [ __ ] like that I
think arrow arrow blu-ray just put out a
really nice blu-ray set but if I don't
look and everything kind of like imagine
if from beyond was a porno movie and it
kind of was already beyond that you're
gonna love this you'll be totally into
this yeah but yeah so the main character
whose name is Bill Whitney now he lives
in Beverly Hills with his you know
snooty as parents and his like beautiful
blonde sister and all this other kind of
[ __ ] he has like they just bought him a
Jeep he's like really popular at school
he's a basketball players on the debate
team blah-dee-blah
and yet he still feels like something is
a little off you know what I mean so
he's like you know initially it's they
set it up and maybe I'm not sure if
Bryan doesn't it did this on purpose but
the fact that he cast like a soap opera
actor and you know one of the women in
it later on like the woman that plays
Clarissa that dark-haired woman that
yeah kind of gets it her so she was like
a Playboy Playmate yeah so I think he
kind of did that on purpose to kind of
give it this veneer of like a tease team
yeah glossy and in a weird they subvert
it in a weird way it's coming at you
like back to the future it feels like
more to me it is kind of like like
Michael J Fox
he is very Michael J Fox yeah yeah I
noticed like even his voice is the same
and some of this like facial expressions
yeah it isn't super look like him but
some of the bases that he may imagine
and marty mcfly got sucked into a damn
paranormal but yeah so he starts to
think something is off he's like talking
to his therapist about it like he thinks
maybe he's adopted like he just feels
like alienated like from his family now
as I said it's on
the first hour of it almost plays out is
like a teen comedy but with like a
little bit of a mystery element to it -
its shot almost like a soap opera like a
teen comedy but there's like little
weird that you know little weird hints
that maybe something is not entirely
right in this supposedly idyllic life
that this teenage boy is leading it's
like for example like he comes home one
day and he has this sister and the
sisters name is Jenny which is you know
obviously that's not my name but she
doesn't look anything like me but um so
there's this weird like almost like
sexual tension between the two of them
like even from the beginning so you're
des like oh that's a little
uncomfortable like you know they don't
like super it's not like super
in-your-face
no they're not acting like brothers and
sisters they're really not know um yeah
before I even saw what was coming I'm
looking at him and going like I don't
buy that as a brother sister yeah
there's a reason just bad acting I was
like you know looks like bad accident
because some of the things and I'm and
I've read and like seen a lot of reviews
of this and some people said are they
acting is bad and stuff like that I
don't necessarily think that's the case
because like I said this is a satire
yeah um and it was written as a satire
so I kind of feel like he almost wanted
not necessarily bad acting but he wanted
um the next natural nobody acts
naturally because and there's a reason
for that like later I think they're
setting it up oh yeah it was a setup
I mean I was watching it going like boy
that's bad acting because I can tell us
to her [ __ ] yeah do the acting I
thought was just you know I mean this
dude forgot to act he's been knocking
that down yeah I can tell but that comes
out where yeah this is an incest themed
and [ __ ] you don't I mean it's just you
just gotta see it to understand it yeah
it's not normal no it's not yeah and
like I said so there's like little hints
that are like like his parents who were
like really weird and so they're like
out in the garden like talking to their
gardener and the gardener has like this
tray with all these slugs on it and he's
like picking them up with chopstick
and like the parents are like looking at
them going oh this is a nice crop we
have this year so it's like just creepy
[ __ ] like that right yeah then like he
goes like Billy goes into the bathroom
like he's looking for the suntan lotion
or something like that and his sister is
in the shower and you see her in the
shower like through the frosted glass
but it looks like her heads on backwards
you know what I mean so like there's
these big fake titties and laughs
because of glass and everything like
that but her head is like turned that
way and he's like what the [ __ ] and then
like I open it but it's normal Katie's
are on the back yeah so tits and ass on
the same side that's right I'm saying
evolutionary evolutionary wise the
titties are on the back those look like
titties and the titties are supposed to
look like as a woman looks going looks
good too am an evolutionarily the idea
now we also need tits on the side and we
can also look good from the side but
tits on the tips section yeah yeah yeah
yeah that's gonna be the future of
implants girl gets implants and then the
implants get implants like ear first
yeah like scoops of ice cream and [ __ ] a
bikinis guy bikini had a multi-layered
and [ __ ] you know I mean their bras got
like three sets of cups every size you
know sign the real freaky women the cups
get bigger okay he's master Thomas yeah
yeah yeah that's way in the future
that's like 200 years from the future of
these freaking [ __ ] started
doing stuff like that yeah yeah just
like tits with like a bunch of like
dicks having dicks I mean we already got
a lot of dicks run around with dicks
itself has no itself as I said it's like
it's like a endless like yeah yeah
hypersexuality well yeah so there's
these little hints that like there's
some weird [ __ ] going on and then it
turns out the sister Jenny is having her
coming-out party which is I guess was a
thing that many people did like you know
it's like old school she that's old
school rich people stuff I guess they
end
deucer select society like oh you're
allowed to date her now yeah we're
taking the veil off of her yeah unlock
the doors she can come out around the
seal she's available she pay up first
though
give us some sheep and goats Ajith but
yeah so so it turns out that they're
having this coming-out party and billy
can't go cuz he has some big basketball
game or some [ __ ] like that but it turns
out that Jenny's ex-boyfriend who has
kind of been stalking her a little bit
and you think like what did what a
scumbag but later on you find out why
she is actually put like a secret
microphone like or something like in her
earring so she's wearing earrings and
like recording everything so this cot is
so this guy comes to Billy and it's like
you need to loosen this [ __ ] right now
plays him a tape of Jenny's coming-out
party and it sounds like everyone's
having a big incestuous orgy like not
just the parents [ __ ] the daughter
but also the daughter [ __ ] pretty
much everybody everybody [ __ ] the
daughter everybody [ __ ] everybody
and then there seems to be like a guy
screaming and there's like all these
weird like suction noises and stuff
though he's like what the [ __ ] is going
on like what are they doing and all this
other kind of [ __ ] and then you start
thinking they must better eaten slugs
yeah yeah so he's so he goes and he
tells his um therapist dr. Cleveland
about this and he's like no I'm right
you know but this guy Blanchard his
friend who was his sister's ex-boyfriend
it's like you've recorded this look you
know you got to listen to this now the
doctor was like I'm not gonna listen to
it right now I'll listen to an N I
promise and stuff like that now when
Billy comes back the next day the tape
is totally innocuous it's just like a
regular party like and so Billy starts
thinking that he's losing his mind you
know what I mean so I really like like
the build-up of this cuz I you know some
people that reviewed it say it's like oh
you know it takes a long time like cuz
the ending of it is just so batshit
crazy that it takes like too long to
build up to that but I really like like
the first hour where it's like this
paranoid thing where it's like Billy
actually thinks he might be losing his
mind because it seems like he's seeing
all this stuff but then when he goes
back to the you know like he goes back
to listen to the tape
the doctor plays in the tape and it's
totally normal and he's like what the
[ __ ] like how did I hear this other kind
of [ __ ]
so then he tries to go to Blanchard like
to get another copy of the tape and when
he gets there there's like been a big
car accident and supposedly Blanchard is
dead so there's like all this nefarious
so it seems like everybody's in on the
ship but him it's like some paranoia
like Rosemary's Baby type action going
on where everybody's in on the joke you
know except for him so like I said for
the first like hour you're thinking that
either he's going crazy or everybody's
in on [ __ ] um now he also meets this
like I said this play Playboy Playmate
she's not she is in real life she wasn't
in the movie named Clarissa and funniest
things about this is that her mom for
some reason and they don't ever really
explain this her mom is like this big
gigantic mountain of a woman who kind of
looks like Tammy Faye like with the
makeup kind of [ __ ] and kind of looks
like a really bad drag queen and also
and also does it talk she's a mute umm
maybe kind of mentally impaired not
entirely sure on that also eats hair and
coughs up hair balls that's right
yeah and the [ __ ] that she does it's
weird so anyway I've kind of thought
they were all aliens they are not aliens
because I mean specifically okay so
after all that kind of [ __ ] happens they
kind of faked Billy's death and all this
other stuff so Lenny when he gets back
to the house
and you discover like what the big
secret is behind quote-unquote society
is that basically all of these rich
people that live in Beverly Hills and
everything like that are they're not
aliens because the ahead of them who's
like judge whatever the hell his name is
he specifically says that we're not from
outer space or anything like that it's
like we've been here as long as you have
or we've been longer than you have so
they're a different species like ISOs
essentially so species a human and but
because of like good breeding yeah
they're they're making it they're making
a metaphor about like the rich being a
different species yeah yeah
right yeah and that the end that the
rich are like yeah and you were like
having sex they've been all kind of like
merge in into one body kind of like they
were big bunch it's like an amoeba yeah
and then weird stuff it happened and
guys that pop out dead guys acid pop out
he's talking out his ass [ __ ] bizarre
kind of kind of like it's kind of its
kind of that part kind of reminded me of
Naked Lunch now yeah now here's the
thing seeing it now I just thought it
was bizarre kind of funny yeah I would
have liked to have seen him back in the
day that it came out yeah in 92 or 89
evidently I first came out or because I
think it would have had a little bit of
a different impact on you back then yeah
because you know it seems so much [ __ ]
now nothing really surprises you but I
think how that series from those that
director and everything how it built up
that probably was the logical next step
and the aggression to that series of
movies that he was making yeah and I
would have liked to have seen it on the
top in the time in which it would have
been yest because I couldn't think I was
really kind of getting the proper
context the cultural content yeah and
and I don't I barely remember what 92
was like yeah yeah I mean I was in the
army so I didn't I wasn't a civilian
then so I don't know what kind of
cultural impact it would have had they
said that it didn't make a cultural
impact that it well no but I think what
is I think they were actually revolted
by it I can see that it's probably what
happened I have to say the practical
effects in this which were done by
screaming mad George who's a Japanese
fella who had also done many other very
famous he is a very famous for doing
like these kind of surrealistic gore
effects which is why they wanted him for
this the special effects in this you
know a lot of the stuff this was made in
1989 so a lot of the fashions automated
it's very very 80s and stuff but the
effects in this are amazing yeah they're
good and you can tell that that's
emotional effects it really but they
really are there yeah not CG and it's a
bunch of latex and stuff in it and they
did a good job I mean it still looks
like pretty
awesome I sleep in the budget it's a
low-budget movie oh yeah um now you can
tell that the that a lot of the
inspiration for the effects came from
like you know Bosch paintings yeah they
one of them said they they were using
his inspiration the Dali painting the
great master baiter um so it's almost
kind of like this vision of Hell where
there's like these all these people and
a lot of them are like kind of
middle-aged or like older people they're
all standing around in their underwear
they call it the shunting by the way
that's the name of the thing that
they're doing okay and so so you get
like these shots of just like all these
bodies and they're like just meshing
together there's like all this drippy
latex and I was like and they're melting
into and they and what they do is they
take these quote-unquote
you know poor people because it turns
out that Billy is not their biological
child he was taken in by them as so he
would be a sacrifice later on they were
almost like growing him that was what
they met with the slugs or like oh it's
a good crop this year they raised them
in their you know yes until you there
it's an allegory of what really happened
out on Epstein's Island is that it's a
teracle takedown and there's like you
know the rich people and how they're
like sovereigns are like abusing the
poor yeah so actually and in this case
like they're kind of literally absorbing
that so it's like the one that like a
backwards thing now the thing can yeah
you know people they're mesh it melting
together they're all melting together I
mean there is like some crazy like
[ __ ] Vashi and imagery in this like I
said they're this kid because Blanchard
is the one that gets it first because
it's him and Billie and they're at this
at the shunting party and that they're
gonna get absorbed so Blanchard gets it
solved it gets absorbed first and then
like they're all just gathering around
him and they're just like starting to
suck around and everything like that and
then the judge there's a hold Nathan and
he's like in a whole bunch of movies
that actor and it's like man fair play
to him because everybody committed to
this [ __ ] is [ __ ]
as it is he takes his [ __ ] fist
shoves it up Blanchard's ass the hand
comes out now it's not really up in ask
people but yeah it's like so there's
just like just these [ __ ] great gags
man it's like the you know when Billy
goes up and he sees his mom and she just
see her top half at the arms but then
where her legs are there's other arms
and then like she's walking the arms
then she bends over and like the
daughters face comes out of her ass or
her [ __ ] or whatever and then like the
dad just has his like his ass in the
face is like his face is in the middle
it's just the craziest [ __ ] [ __ ] and
it's like I think um says if the thing
was a porno movie it is very much like
that it is it is very thing like it's
really a Bravo teen but like I said it
was screwing my George who did the
effects and they're just like they're
disgusting and delightful and you have
never seen anything like this I I can
assure he is bizarre and I think Billy
at the end too he's fighting with that
other that other douchebag that's like
his whatever and he he does the same
thing where he sticks his hand all the
way up the dudes asked grabs his mouth
he Kissin and then he pulls him
completely inside out and imagine all
this amaze and all this is happening in
a movie this kind of like Back to the
Future
yeah or like or like dynasty or falcon
crest or like one of those nighttime
soap opera it's just the craziest [ __ ]
you've ever seen and like I said it's
that's kind of what's so cool about it
and it's I know that's kind of like a
cult classic nowadays and like I said
era just have like a big really fancy
like two disc blu-ray release with like
a comic book and everything like that um
but I do feel like this is one that kind
of gets forgotten about as famous as
Brian Jasna is particularly for working
on the reanimate or films and she had
him and Stuart Gordon even didn't Honey
I Shrunk the Kids for [ __ ]
Disney isn't that crazy yeah what do you
think about that but this is you know
this being his first movie and as
notorious as the like the last 20
minutes of
are you would think that it would be
better known but I guess it it kind of
isn't I think you just went over the top
492 I guess some that they didn't want
they didn't want the public to see maybe
it made the wrong people mad yeah it's
just made rich people mad they don't war
don't show my guess is a fool it's like
really funny to me because like I said
it was released three years earlier in
Europe and it got like oh they got
really really positive reviews like
especially in the UK like they [ __ ]
loved it um you know what I mean and
it's just it's very funny to me that it
took so long to come out over here and
that it just cut you know it whatever
like a wet fart pretty much yeah which
you know really weird and like I said
it's it's not like there wasn't other
satirical horror that I mean people had
done they live there was this there was
a lot of them in the eighties
particularly um you know [ __ ] like
Street trash and stuff like that but I
don't know for some reason this one just
didn't maybe just because the ending was
just way too gross or weird for people I
don't know I mean the end of it is
really a super clean nightmarish I guess
not even like but seriously if you
haven't seen this movie you need to see
it because true that yeah it's really
trippy it's like I was this one review I
was reading it was so funny it's like
who's who put acid in my mouth look it's
like [ __ ] sneaky Brian knows no dude
that's exactly it it just it's like a
Bosch painting come to life but even
like before that it's kind of like a
cool like little build up little
paranoia mystery type of thing so if you
like these kind of like conspiracy
paranormal you know paranoia you know
type of movies where and and also you
gotta like body horror because I have um
if you're squeamish the end of it's
pretty [ __ ] gross and I'm not gonna
lie but yeah it's on shudder at the
moment so you should probably go check
it out if you haven't seen it even
though we just boiled the whole thing
but we did warn you so I'm telling you
alright so we will see you next time bye